Can I go back on the supplements and not tell the oncologist and my body will be okay or benefited?
Well, I can't tell you not to tell your oncologist thing, so, you know,
but I will tell you that with vast majority of people that do natural things, don't
explain those natural things to their regular medical doctor or oncologist or
Because they, you know, you might as well talk to the wall and
I mean, you just got to understand everybody's got to stay in their lane
I try to give them as much grace as possible. They just they they have enough things to worry about they're seeing
You know, 50 patients a day and they don't have time to study natural things
Okay, that's an excuse. They're lazy. They should be knowing how to take care of their patients, but
It is what it is so you could tell you what to do there, but
I don't think they're being harmed now if you are take if you are doing a chemo therapy
That's an oxidizing agent that I would have to look back at your supplements and make sure you're not taking any antioxidants